hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
membrane proteins from gene to cryo-em
structure with thermo-fisher gene art
and salipro biotech i am jennifer woods
of labrutz and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
michael liss senior manager r d at
thermo fisher scientific
doctor yiva julita cryo em application
scientist at thermo fisher scientific
and dr janz rohenfeld ceo and founder of
salapro biotech ab
welcome you may now begin your
presentations
so thank you very much for the nice
introduction and thanks very much for
introducing
our webinar today
which will be around workflow which we
designed to attain
primary ammo structures quickly when you
just start from electronic data
of genes and or proteins
so the entire workflow of this
of this
procedure
starts with
gene synthesis
we start a gene art with a
protein sequence for example
that translated into dna
and design it for optimal expression i
will explain a little bit later what
that is
so then of course starts turning the
electronic data into a tangible molecule
through gene synthesis and the
transfection into mammalian cells for
the expression
the next step in our collaboration is
then with celiprobiotec
who is
specialized on one-step reconstruction
and
purification
of the membrane proteins from the cell
pellets that we send them
screen them and do the production
analysis of course
finally it ends up with thermofisher
again
which takes the
specimen
proteins prepares them for cryo-em
freezes them does the data collection
and the image reconstruction to end up
with the structure
so the first part gene synthesis
starts as i said with electronic data
of a protein
optimized
in silico and then
put into molecules through regular
oligosynthesis these oligos are then
assembled to attain full-length
double-stranded dna this is cloned into
expression vector we use in this study
pc dna 3.4
sequence verification and then typically
we ship these genes to our customers if
it's just gene synthesis but here we go
one step further
what you can see here you may know that
gene synthesis is a very competitive
market so we put a lot of emphasis on
miniaturization and automation of the
gene synthesis process itself
um
and um
therefore attain uh
very high throughput capacity and very
short turnaround times of our services
so that was gene synthesis
after gene synthesis what we do and also
offer to customers was a custom service
is upscaling the plasmids of the
expression plus of the expression
construct
and then transfect
we use mainly xp293 xp joe that also can
go into insect cells sf9
and eventually end up with a protein
purification so this entire process
allows customers to order their protein
of choice purified from genoite
i talked about optimization so the first
step in still in
silicon what is gene optimization it's a
multi-parameter
algorithm
that takes several parameters into
account that contribute to high
expression of genes and that very
obvious it's the codon usage which is
not equal in every organism
and the gc content
you may know that high gc content genes
express better in romanian cells of
course we eliminate cryptic supply sides
that may be present in the cdna or in
the dna of other origin
avoid instability sequences secondary
structures and so on so the list is long
it's up to 20 parameters
and that algorithm is actually not
trivial because the algorithm tries to
find the best possible solution
given all the possible codon
combinations which is of course an
astronomical high number
so does that actually work
gene optimization and here's
some data from a paper we published
about 10 years ago
in which we took 50 standard human genes
and optimized them for
human expression
so you may know you may think about a
human gene why isn't that already
optimized for expression but of course
the genes that we have in our body are
not optimized for highest expression
but for highest
functionality in the concerted
[Music]
work network of of the cellular
metabolism
so
here's the data from some data from that
study five sample proteins
from the
five different
classes so for example the first one the
transcription factor grab one
you see in triplicates the wild type
expression on the left hand side versus
the
optimized expression and the same is
true for rhizoma or other proteins and
kinases membrane proteins and cytokines
on the bottom you see the cytokine is
barely visible only in the optimized
whereas the optimized version while the
y version gave no detectable expression
at all
in total in this study we observed that
from the 50 proteins 86
of those had a significantly better
expression than wild type 10
were indistinguishable from white type
and only one case
so
two cases four percent
were had a lower expression than the
optimize so it's not bulletproof but
gives a pretty good
result
here's something about non-membrane
proteins what customers can expect when
they order from us this is examples from
antibodies expressed in xp joe
either in 24
well format or down there it's 96 well
formed
so you see you can see heavy and light
chain
on the top
uh komasi it's just conditioned media so
crude supernatant from the cells which
you can obtain
and down there is the purified antibody
which we also offer on the right hand
side
you see
different qcs that we offer
size exclusion capillary gel
electrolysis and mass spec
so
uh in total
what you can get from gene art is not
just gene synthesis but also protein
expression which is all unhoused so
there's no wet work left on your side
if you choose to
use this service
all the reagents are proprietary
reliable and
optimized for high expression
the scales that we offer
range from 30 milliliter up to 25 liter
in
wave back format but we also offer high
for put formats in 26 and 96 multiple
formats
so
coming to
our actual project here where we
concentrate
genes
we chose
four
representative proteins two ion channels
and two
gpcrs
which
are of clinical relevance either in
cancer and hiv
infection in pain
and
designed these to be
to
have high expression in mammalian system
we add it to some of these proteins
precision
cleavage tags and egfp
and
also of course detection tags like his
flag or c
tag then we express those in 293 cells
in five liter scale
and the watched cell pellet
was then shipped to solipro and i will
here
hand over to
ins to
continue what they are doing
with their magics what they are doing
with our cell
phones thanks a lot um
michael for the introduction
um yeah welcome everyone my name is uh
jens
um
i will basically describe the workflow
now once we receive the cell palette
from from michael and his team
just a few words in our company um
we are located here in stockholm and
here on the you can see the the view of
the city and where this little dot are
that's approximately our location so
rather in the city center
we are collaborating with pharma and
biotech companies and have a fully owned
ip portfolio that covers our platform
technology
um
today we have 38 discovery programs in
several stages with 15 partners or
collaborators including seven of the top
20 pharma companies and you can see a
selection
of some of our partners and
collaborators
and
what we're doing at cytoprobiotec is
we're working with membrane proteins and
um
michael already introduced membrane
proteins to us
um
explaining the relevance in in the in
the drug discovery process so
starting from scratch if you look at the
surface here of of the cell
um
you can see there's you have the cell
membrane and there's a couple of
proteins sticking out of the membrane
which which are which are the membrane
proteins and they are really interesting
drug targets so this one membrane
protein here in the front could be a
very interesting drug target in in
oncology
uh the protein in the back could be very
interesting drug target in diabetes
or in in pain for example
so all in all they're really interesting
for drug discovery
uh whatever they're pretty pretty
challenging to work with and the
challenge actually starts
um with a membrane and this is what you
see here so in orange you can see the
membrane protein
which is then embedded in this gray
lipid bilayer and we're moving towards
the more schematic version that you can
see here on the right where is the
membrane protein
and then the transmembrane regions and
you can see that the membrane protein is
surrounded by this lipid bilayer and
those those lipids this lipid bilayer
has has a very strong effect on the
function and the stability of the
membrane protein so you can see for
example
those lipids they have charged head
groups so there could be positively
charged head groups and it could be
negatively charged have groups and those
head groups they specifically interact
with specific side chains
of the membrane protein same is true for
those rsu chains from the lipids that
have different lengths different angles
and they also specifically interact with
the transmembrane helices of the
membrane protein and
our philosophy here solid probiotic is
actually that the membrane protein and
the lipids they together form a unit
basically they belong together and if
you want to investigate a membrane
protein
properly you should make sure that you
have the lipids lips around
one of the problems is in the drug
discovery process and especially for for
cryo-em
at some point you want to isolate your
specific membrane proteins from all the
others basically because you want to get
the 3d structure you want to make
specific antibodies
um so several reasons why people want to
isolate the specific membrane proteins
out of the cell membrane context
and the most common approach to do so is
to use detergents and those detergents
what they're doing is actually they are
replacing
[Music]
those lipids
and then make the entire membrane
protein soluble to bring it into
solution so you can isolate it the
problem is that those detergents are
very often just a poor mimic of those
lipids because they're lacking the the
specific charges the specific
um a suit chains for example
and very often you lose the stability or
functionality or you have maybe you also
strip away some important binding
partners or you maybe disrupt the entire
association of the membrane protein with
its partners basically so detergents
are
a bit tricky to handle basically there's
there's several ways to work around that
problem and one way for example is that
you could engineer uh your membrane
protein in for example by introducing
thermostabilizing mutations you could
for example add
other domains for example
but it always involves heavy engineering
and this is
a more non-natural approach basically
and it takes a lot of time also to find
that specific mutations
in other ways basically you just cut
away the transmembrane part and work
with the with the soluble regions
or just peptides basically but here
again this is a very unnatural
approach and
very artificial you don't know what
if this is the real thing or if you if
it's too much engineered actually
uh other approaches which are not
entirely relevant for for triumph but
but also being used in in the drug
discovery process is
um
that you are using uh cells expressing
the target of interest or vlps but they
also come with pros and cons in the
process with a high background noise and
uh
batch to batch variations so in general
uh there's a lot of really interesting
membrane proteins out there um
which could be really interesting drug
target but the problem is with the
current approaches
very often those membrane proteins are
are undruggable basically because you
can't really work with them due to this
lack of stability and functionality
basically
and
basically that's when when we
tried to to find a solution for this
major problem
and
we basically started then back from from
the cell membrane
so um
we've developed the solution platform
basically to to ch to solve some of
those problems that i've just described
um so we start with it with a membrane
protein in the cell or in the cell
membrane
and then in the next step we're adding
uh the solupro scaffold protein and
which which has a high affinity for
lipids and this solid prosceptor protein
would basically grab
the membrane protein together with some
of the lipids that are surrounding the
membrane protein
and then scoop them out and then form a
complex which contains the membrane
protein
number of lipids and then there's the
cytochrome scaffold which holds
everything together
in a ring shape format and
here in the next slide you can see a
representative scribium structure which
was published in nature in 2018 uh where
you can see uh an ion channel in orange
and then you can see in blue you can see
the scaffold protein how it makes a ring
around the transmembrane regions and
some lipids of the membrane protein and
keeping everything everything in shape
and then which then enables
the researchers to basically investigate
the 3d structure or use it for for drug
discovery processes and that's several
publications in the public domain now uh
showing that
the use of our technology for structure
function
research on on specific drug targets
basically
um
so we have this now this very bold claim
by saying
well the notion that the majority of
memory proteins is undruggable maybe
it's no longer true because if you start
using the cyprus system then maybe that
fixes some of the problems and you can
actually start working with some of the
more challenging membrane proteins
and as michael already introduced um
we wanted to showcase this with a couple
of uh of targets
uh two gpcrs and two iron channels and
um
we heard the introduction from michael
from gnard uh that we've chosen four
different targets which were over
expressed in
293 cells basically and then they they
shipped us the cell pallets basically
and that's where we took over
um so here's finally pro we have the the
soundproof platform and the and the
process which is called direct membrane
extraction direct mx
and what we've done is we've basically
for every single of those membrane
proteins we've we've adjusted and
tailored
uh our platform technology for this
specific drug target so um that in the
end we have a stabilized
membrane clouding in the cylindrical
system that is then ready uh for
cryogram
which we would then ship to to eva
for further investigation on on cry
electron microscopy
so the first target that we started
working with is is an eye channel called
panic scene
um
when we receive then the the cell
palettes and uh this is basically like
an overview of what we call direct mx or
direct membrane extraction
um so we have here the cell
cell membrane with panic scene that
contains a
strep tag and a gfp
but there's also other membrane proteins
that you can see and in the first step
basically we are adding the scaffold
protein
to the cell membrane
and then in the second step this will
then basically extract all of the
membrane proteins uh and this is
something that we call the cytochrome
membrane proteome because basically we
have all membrane chlorines extracted um
but then the next step we want to
isolate the membrane clothing of choice
in this case panic scene and then here
we use the strap tag uh and used
affinity chromatography and then
immobilized it um
on the
on the matrix and then we used um we
cleaved off actually the gfp strap
and then we could elude the purified um
punishing solid propanoxine particles
whereas all the unwanted membrane
proteins are in the wash or in the flow
through fractions basically so
this is now
if we then if you then take the illusion
and put it on the size exclusion
chromatography
then you will get the following profile
and please note that the buffer is only
hypers and salt there's no detergent
there's no additives it's a very plain
uh buffer setup that we have here and we
can see a piece that corresponds to
cytopropanic scene if we analyze those
fractions um
you can see it here
we have a band for panic scene and
another protein band for the scaffold
protein that you can see here and then
if we pull the the specific reflections
and then what we usually do is we freeze
we freeze our samples and then we throw
them and then we analyzed them again
on site exclusion to make sure they're
surviving the the freeze throwing but
also we're testing thermal stability on
on defined terms in this case
we
froze it we thought it then we kept it
for 16 hours at 4 degrees
or for 16 hours at 22 degrees and you
can see here in the sec profile there's
no changes uh even after longer
incubation on elevated temperatures so
we have basically extracted this phonic
scene
from
from xp293 cells directly they eluded as
pure and homogeneous particles and they
were really stable even after flash
freezing thawing and then this
subsequent incubation at different
temperatures um so with this sample then
we we basically then
shipped and sent it to yeva
for further investigation and now you
have to be patient until it's the
earbuds part to show you more about the
structures
in the meantime uh we continue here with
a with a gpcr cxcr4
um which was also part of of this array
of different drug targets that we chose
um
similar purification strategy like
before i jump directly to the size um
exclusion chromatography program program
so on here we can see cx cl4
the bands
which are visible here and then we see
the the scaffold protein bands and here
again we then collected those fractions
we pulled them
and then here again we then flash flows
the sample we thought it and then
subsequently incubated it at different
temperatures we in this case it was 24
hours at 4 degrees and 24 hours at 23
degrees and note that for all those um
gene sequences we we
basically chose the wild type so there's
no thermal stabilizing mutations
in this one
and again the buffer is just hepas and
salt there's no additives no ligands uh
just basically the
the protein and and the very quest
buffer
and again the particles were homogeneous
pure and stable uh even after longer
incubation and then again we chose
we basically took this sample and sent
it over to heber and again stay tuned
for 3d images of of this membrane
protein
when give us going to present us more
about that
um
then we continued with another ion
channel um trip three three in this case
um
similar to before we did the the
affinity purification with the size
exclusion and then we pulled the
fractions the relevant ones and you can
see again after incubation uh after
flash freezing thawing and then
subsequent incubations for 16 hours
at 4 degrees and at room temperature
that trip v is also very stable
and
the protein uh the ss page is also uh
indicating that we only have subocean
present and then the the chip v three
bands basically
uh last but not least was then
another gpcr a1r
here again similar similar setups so we
started
with
the
with affinity purification size
exclusion and then continued
with analyzes and here again flash
freezing followed by thawing and
substituent incubation at four degrees
and at room temperature
and
we have a pretty robust setup of a1r as
well
so these were the four targets that we
that we um
selected and then basically
shipped them to yeva and then uh from
here on yeah well then present you more
about uh the general setup of of cryom
and then more specifics on the drug
targets that we investigated so thank
you and then happy to catch up later
uh thank you again and hi everyone hi
i'm yava i'm an application scientist at
dermot fisher
and uh let me tell you now about the
last step that these proteins took in
their journey from germany to sweden and
then to the netherlands to
go on our microscopes
um
okay
so let's start more generally uh drug
discovery pipelines
can consist of
soluble proteins it could be small uh
antibodies or multimeter complexes or it
consists of membrane proteins such as
iron channels and gpcrs
but unfortunately up to 60 percent of
the pipelines are not structurally
enabled and that could be because the
tigers are not known or they're
disordered it could be hard to purify or
to crystallize crayons does not require
crystals and can deal with
some degree of sample heterogeneity so
this technique is well suited for uh
determining structures of membrane
proteins and by using cryo we can
increase
the percentage of pipelines that can
benefit from a structure-based drug
design
the crime impacting is impacting drug
discovery on various types of targets
for example cryo-em can be used to gain
insight into targeted protein
degradation or formation of high order
target antibody complexes uh such as
retuxamab
and c20
we can use this technique to
structurally enable targets which resist
crystallization or
adopt many conformational states for
example kinases
and crime has been successfully used to
determine many structures of
trip channels and high resolution
structures of double receptors with
ligands and also active stage gpcrs
and evidence to the value of chlorine
for membrane proteins can be illustrated
with this graph over here so
historically x-ray crystallography was
used for determining the structures of
ion channels but as of 2020 crime has
taken over and as you can see from this
graph
most human ion channels and now are now
uh
structurally solved by cryo-er and you
can see an example of one a crime
structure in the ant channel here on the
right this is south to uh 3a iron
channel
and
now let's get back to our
workflow that we're presenting in this
webinar you heard from
michael about how the genes were
synthesized and proteins were expressed
and from yemen's about how these
membrane proteins were purified and now
i will talk about the
the cryon part so there are four major
steps in this workflow so first the
samples need to be plunged frozen to
make a really thin layer of
particles in vitreous ice and then we
want to
screen these samples and collect data on
a transmission electron microscope
and then we end up with a stack of raw
images and then in these four images we
want to take particles
extract them classify them and take the
best jack of particles forward to
reconstruct a vdd volume
and so the first step is is really
important in this workflow and is cryo
em grid optimization
uh all samples that i will talk about
were vitrified using quantum foil i 1.2
1.3 grid and using a little box mark 4
lunch freezer
and
a good optimization involves a
vitrifying sample by making sure that
the ice is thin enough and you have
the right concentration of particles in
ice and that these particles adopt
random orientations as much as possible
but it is a well-known
factor in chromium that particles
do not always adopt random orientations
and and it likes to
adopt prepare orientations in
this digified ice so to improve
orientation distribution and to
to help with the reconstructions
with just right before plunge freezing i
added a little bit of
mild uh detergents of fluorinated
phosgolene 8 below the cnc level just to
improve this orientation
distribution and
uh you can see here for the silo pro
connection one adding a bit of detergent
it helps to improve
these in orientations and we can we
could see a lot more sizes in 2d class
averages and and similar effect
was observed with silent price cxcr4 as
when we added more of the detergent we
saw a better angular distribution plot
in the final reconstruction
so let's now
go and jump into the processing of the
data for by next in
one channel
and in total i collected
nearly 8 000
micrographs in a one-day session on a on
a microscope on acrylic g4
and from this data set i picked 1.3
million particles and performed 2d
classification you can see some
representative the class averages uh on
the top right
um
then um most of the pressing was done in
reliance and uh
this was followed by 3d classification
so you can see that 8 resulting
3d classes and i chose the one on the
very right box in
green
and took all the particles from that
class and
refine them to produce a
3.1 angstrom
refinement and the bottom right you can
see an angular distribution plot so now
let's have a look at the
cryo em density you see the
connection one
uh
map in
yellow orange and when you lower
specials you also see there's a potent
scaffold protein transparent blue
and um
yeah we could see that the uh
channel has c7 symmetry and
what most most of it was really well
resolved and we're in the process of now
building a bundle
so let's jump into the next target so
that's a trip v3
and i want to say that i received the
sample from
stockholm just last thursday and
it went
onto the microscope into our glacious
cryotim last friday so this is really a
hot off the of the press and this data i
i made some grits and i cleaned them the
ice was like a little bit thick so i i
think just
this project needs a little more
optimization uh to get thinner eyes but
uh nevertheless i collected a data set
after the screening uh two and a half
thousand movies uh from which i picked a
little bit over half a million particles
and
here on the right you can see two
d-class averages of uh cylipro v3 and
after civil 2d classification i took the
best 150 000 particles for initial
reconstruction and then the third class
the one with a green
box
is the best it shows that the
the protein of the right shape so i took
these particles about 100 000 particles
and
performs non-uniform refinement to guess
a4 angstrom uh reconstruction
and in this slide now you can see the
cryo emf of a solid project b3 you can
see that it consists of forces units and
once again
when you lower the threshold you can see
the supposing
i suppose in scaffold
in transparent blue
i could also fit
uh the existing structure of uh trophy
three into the density and corresponds
really well so and now the next steps
are just
to do a little bit more of good
optimization and improve the resolution
okay and now to the final
of the uh the three proteins i will talk
about
so the final one is the chemokine or
receptors it's dxcr4
um yeah for this project i collected
six thousand uh micrographs and from
these micrographs i picked three hundred
thousand particles and perform two
rounds of 3d classification so on the
top right you see 2d class averages you
can see it
you can see that there is
definitely a different view some side
views and some toffees
and then the best
class particles belonging to the best 2d
class averages were taken for
um
initial reconstruction into five classes
and you can see the best of initial
class
box in green and this class consisted of
64 000 particles and i've extracted them
and refined them to produce a 3.2
angstrom map what's also interesting to
mention that when i collected the data
as before motion correction on the fly
and then i took the align images and
uploaded them to
our
s3 packet on aws and i did the rest of
the processing
on
aws
a100 gpu instances
and i calculated the time that it took
the gpu time that it took to go from the
motion corrected images to the final
reconstruction and it was a little bit
less than 12 hours which just shows the
how quick the processing can go for such
a project
so now uh let's have a look at the
now let's have a look at the cryo
cryo-em map
you can see
that
cscxdr4 is a tetramer and we can see
as opposing disk in transparent blue
i took a
sorry then
you need to change the slide yeah uh so
i took this exercise model from the
alpha volt2 database and it fits really
well in the map and you can see on the
left side that the side chain
density corresponds to
the world with a bulky side chain
and
lastly i also wanted to
um
bring your attention to some additional
densities that are visible in the ear
maps right as yank was uh saying that
and in
when these proteins are purified with
substance scaffolds
lipids can be
scooped out of membrane together for
protein and we think that some of these
additional densities might be exactly
that so
there are definitely uh additional long
tubular densities visible between the
subunits and also on the outside of the
protein as well as the
in the inside when we look uh for the
central slide so this could be uh lipids
or
other hydrophobic molecules and we're
now in the process of
investigating what these are
so
this is my last slide and i would like
to
pass it back the presentation back to
you
excellent thanks eva
um
yeah now um
wrapping wrapping um
this uh initial presentation up
um
so we've seen basically how we started
from
from basically just
genes
that were synthesized and then over
expressed into into crude cell patterns
uh then we tailored our platform
technology on each specific membrane
protein and then we send those samples
uh to yevahu then as you could see
in a really straightforward process
generated 3d structures of the samples
that we sent
and
basically the only one missing is a1r
but this is basically a
work in process
and
looking at the structures that we have
so far so we have panic scene uh there's
already a couple of crime structures out
there uh we have trip b there's also a
couple of uh crime structures out there
and then we have cx cr4 and for cxtr4
there's so far there's christmas
structures which are engineered with
like thermostabilation mutations or some
inserts basically and they come with a
ligand but uh and they als all of those
uh
cxo4 structures were obtained from
detergent extracted uh membrane protein
basically so
um
we wanted since we saw a tetramer we
wanted to investigate a bit further
basically um with some doing some some
biochemistry as a follow-up to
see what's what we're looking at
basically so web60r4 is if i present it
as a tetrameric form and we already
heard that it's actually
straightforward to fit in
um
the the alpha fault prediction of cxcr4
into the
um
into the density that we observe uh
and then we wanted to investigate okay
but but
thus
this setup that we have um
is it um
is it relevant and then um
in this case so we actually
had a look at we have a look at the
buffer where we have hepas and sword and
we have a very stable and pure cx4 that
you can see here and we've seen the
structure out of it so in the next step
we wanted to investigate well um
how does an antibody which is known to
only binds to functional and structured
properly folded uh cxcr4 how does that
behave with our setup and there's a
there's an antibody called 12g5 which is
also showing to uh
be efficient in um
in in mouse models for example so it
recognizes cxtr4 which is expressed on
cells and we wanted to see
does this specific antibody do the same
to the cx4 that we have in the
cytochrome system basically and then
here we're looking at size exclusion um
profiles where we have started proceeds
cf4
and then we have another peak which then
uh
corresponds to this antibody and then
upon incubation of this antibody with
cxtr4 we see the formation of a complex
uh which is corresponding to solid
procedure f4 with 12 feet 12 g5 which
actually means uh that this 12 g5
actually binds to the cxo4 as we've as
we've seen
validating the the the structure that
we've observed before uh whatever
presented
um then cxtr4 is known to bind its
natural ligand which is called cxe12 um
and here again we did a similar essay so
we uh we used solid pro cxtr4 this is
here the control and then we added we
incubated it with cxtr12
to see if we can observe a binding and
indeed we can so if you look at the at
the size extrusion profile
if you then take those fractions and
analyze them on a gel you can see that
we have cxe12 present here
which co eludes at exactly the same
position
where we have cxcr4 as well basically
we wanted to investigate this further
especially with cxe12 and we used in
this case mass photometry
uh we can see here that cytochrome cxtr4
has a size of approximately 350
kilodalton
and then
when uh when incubating this with cxe12
we see a shift towards 370 kilodalton
um so confirming again what we saw in
the sec profile before that yes the
cxe12 does interact with cxer4 and such
a setup
um and then there's an antagonist which
is called amd three one
three thousand one hundred and uh we
wanted to see if this has an effect on
the binding of cxcr12 cxe12
so when adding um this antagonist
there's actually no major structural uh
or size size difference in in the
particles uh however then if you have
this antagonist present and then you're
adding cxc12
we do not observe any binding again
indicating that this antagonist is
actually
locking cxtr4 in the state which makes
it not possible to to bind cxu12
so with this then
we can summarize that so we have a human
cxtr4
wild type basically which is
reconstituted directly from a human cell
line
into a lipid environment basically using
the silicone platform
um the cx4 is an apple state so it has
never seen any kind of
ligands during the purification process
with experiments that we've shown here
we could show that it binds the natural
ligand cxc12
we could also show that it that it
binds this 12g5 g5 antibody
we could show that the antagonist adm
3100 inhibits the binding of cx12
so
in summary actually
we have a
a nice
tetrameric structure of 604 which
actually is capable of binding cxe12 and
12g5
so interesting structure
and to summarize it um so we've we've
basically now gone from genes to
structures within a a very
straightforward setup
together
with germa fischer where we have panic
scene where cxr4
and
trip v
and uh
waiting for a1r which is going to happen
in the next couple of weeks um and then
together we can basically highlight or
showcase this process basically where we
start
with with an idea of a drug target
which is then translated into gene
synthesis overexpressed in cells
um shipped to scientific biotech where
we then tailor our platform technology
to each specific drug target basically
and then
having this this highly purified
um
memory protein in the static system and
then making it directly
uh
ready to for structural biology uh with
giva
and um
yeah so um with this i think we can
conclude this little webinar uh we would
like to thank um
the camera fischer scientific teams from
green art and the chromium team and all
the team here at startup biotech
some collaborators and
then we also have a have a white paper
already out which you can which you can
access and uh yeah we'd like to thank
you for your attention and we're happy
to take questions now
all right thank you michael yeva and jen
yeah yeah
i'm so sorry for your
mispronouncing your name for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question
if two proteins interact with the
extracellular domain would the
nanoparticle encapsulate both proteins
um
yeah that's so we had cases basically
where we have a membrane protein which
is for example just a single
transmembrane helix and then it has a
large extracellular domain and they
might interact and then
then you could extract this setup
basically so the
the simplest answer is basically
whatever you have in a cell membrane uh
whatever arrangement you have in the
cell membrane can be extracted with a
solid flow system
uh so either either
it is a stable
stable setup then we can extract it as
it is or you can even enhance the this
interaction by adding ligands or binding
partners that will enforce the
dimerization or polygonalization of
whatever you're interested in
all right thank you again
our next question here
um is there a size limit for the
membrane proteins that the salipro
scaffold can work with
no not really i mean we have everything
from from single transmembrances to
56 transmembrane helices so the the
the elegance of the system is is
actually you have it really adjusts to
the size of the membrane protein so
uh it will be several copies of the
solutro scaffold basically which form a
ring around the transmembrane part and
the larger it is you just have more
copies actually which then align and
form a very stable energetically stable
lipids lipid solid pro-membrane protein
setup basically so it will always adjust
to the right size of the membrane
protein
all right thank you again and let's see
next question here does the salipro
method extract membrane proteins from
all compartments er golgi etc or just
the plasma membrane
well that's any kind of membrane works
fine so also it also works for e coli
membranes insect cells uh i mean if if
you can separate for example
mitochondria or er membranes from other
membranes then this has been the
starting point then you can extract from
those subfractions basically so whatever
the membrane is fine
all right great thank you again jens the
next question
what is the difference between the
salaprobe platform and lipid nanodiscs
yeah well i mean essentially what i just
said before the regarding the size so
with the nano discs um this is a very
long uh scaffold protein so it it has a
defined size
um
and that's where the problem starts
because in order to make it stable you
have to adjust the membrane protein and
the amount of lipids basically you have
to match perfectly for the size of the
scaffold and there's now several
scaffold proteins
none of this which have different sizes
but you have to screen basically for the
right size so in the end you have you
have to adjust your membrane protein to
the size of the scaffold protein and our
system is just the opposite so our
system
will
adjust automatically to the size of the
membrane protein this is one one factor
another factor is this direct extraction
where you can basically start directly
from the cell
membrane
that's not really possible using the
classical nanobase technology basically
so two elements in that regard
all right thank you for clarifying that
yens i appreciate it our next question
in the direct mx approach is the
membrane protein directly extracted
using the saposin with no detergent used
to first solubilize the membranes
so in the very first step when we
because
membranes especially when they work at
40 degrees they're pretty rigid
basically so in the very first step when
we contact the solid pro um scaffold
protein with a membrane we add a very
mild detergent but only the first step
and all subsequent steps are completely
detergent free basically so
only initially to disrupt the membrane
partially and then everything is
detergent free
all right thank you again next question
is
does salapro only work with pro with the
protein which has large transmembrane
domains i.e gpcr with seven tms in
another word will a protein with a very
small tm domain benefit from the
cellopro
yeah so as i said before like i mean the
system will always adjust to the size of
the of the membrane protein and we also
have cases where we have a single
transmembrane hideous helix and then for
example diamonds or trimers basically so
it will adjust and then um
solubilize that and then
um
yeah you can visualize it or use it for
whatever antibody development or
spr
okay great thank you
next question
are there any size limitations of the
salapro system for example the radius of
the tm domain also is the size of the
salapro disks the same
of the same protein always the same or
does it vary a lot between each particle
no as you see before i mean first of all
the size is always defined by the
membrane protein and then the scaffold
will always adjust to the size and as
you've seen from those uh size exclusion
profiles we have a very defined uh
distribution so we always have the same
size and then maybe eva can also comment
on that that's basically what you see in
the in the in the net in the clarion
we have a very defined uh particle sizes
there otherwise you wouldn't get too
high resolution if the particles were of
different sizes
are you agreeing there you have a
yes no exactly so if if
the person skirt was different sizes
then we would not see so defined when we
lowered the threshold and i i showed it
for each of the three proteins
so it's consistent
all right thank you both
next question here
what concentration of membrane protein
is ideal for cryo-em and what is the
sort of minimal minimum acceptable
concentration
i think
ideally you want to have
five to ten mixed ml um
anything less than that then
you might have to collect a lot of data
so for all the projects that i spoke uh
today i used
so actually for for connection one i
only used two and a half mix per ml
and
i've collected a little bit more data
and for the other two projects i used
about five mixed per ml so for
that's just for ion channels and um
for uh really small gpcrs for my
personal experience uh especially just
receptor only gpcrs the
higher concentrations are better so to
form really nice monolayers you want to
have 10 or more mixed female
for small gpcrs
thank you yava next question
let's see for the cryo-em what is the
average size of the sapasan disc sapasin
plus lipids included are you able to see
also the sabasin during the
reconstruction
would you say that the sapisin belt is
more tight than for example nanodiscs
i think the question about the like
molecular or weight would go to yens
because you've done more sizes using uh
chromos chromatography so you see the
the increase in size what would you say
would you clarify that
um yeah i mean we see that sort of i
mean we see for example i mean if we
we can actually say that we have i mean
with cxtr4 for example we saw that it's
a tetramer uh but the the exercise was
approximately 350 kilo dalton so we have
four times the gpcr and then the rest it
comes from lipids and the samples in
scaffold and i think we have
approximately
not entirely sure eight eight or ten
subscene scaffold proteins which form
the ring around that one but again the
size is always defined by the membrane
protein plus the the lipids which
surround the membrane protein and then
sabotaging just sticks to the lipids
essentially
so so what you're thinking that's why
cxc added like hundreds less kilo
dolphins right to the mark
uh and then
other questions can i see the suppose
i'm doing the reconstruction yeah so it
i can see it in the 2d class averages
and in this video reconstruction when i
lowered threshold and i
i can't really uh compare it to nanodisk
directly because i have a
limited experience with nanodesks
and yeah
all right thanks uh yeva and jens here
for helping us out with that question
our next question the cxcr4 example the
images show cxcr4 forms a tetramer any
idea that this is physiologically
relevant
that's
that's why we also did these experiments
with it with
with the chemokine and the 12 g5 uh
antibody and the the amd 3100 antagonist
so um
with the experience that we did we feel
uh that and also the good fit from the
from the
previous christmas structures that were
solved so we think this is
physiologically irrelevant um
we've seen basically in literature that
there's dimers or monomers of cx4
there's also tetramers have been
reported in some cellular essays i mean
i can just say we used we used a very
gentle approach so we used the human
cell done we used the human uh gene we
used the wild type we didn't add any
ligands basically and then we used the
softest extraction
uh possible and then the result was
actually
we got a nice structure it was capable
of finding this 12g5 the chemokine and
and this antagonist basically so with
that
we would say yes um but um
okay thank you jens our next question is
for yeva how are the particles picked 2d
and 3d class average
classes selected automatically or
manually
and everything was selected manually
just by examining by eye and building
classes that look sensible without
deleting too much data too early on
thank you okay next question
let's see how are you planning to
improve the resolution
for fbdd
um so of course i think there is a
resolution limit for uh for proteins
because they might be uh just
intrinsically flexible to present degree
but for example for the cxcr4
um the data that i showed today was
collected uh actually from one of the
first grids that i made without too much
optimization
it was quite difficult to find good
areas on the grid and i also collected
it uh on acro on a microscope without
the energy filter or
cold seg and i'm basically planning to
do a little bit of grid optimization and
use a
better technology and see if i can
improve the resolution
all right thank you yepa we have time
for a few more questions
this question is for yen
due to the flexibility of salopro
nanoparticles to adapt different
membrane protein sizes have you observed
any co-extraction of contaminant
membrane proteins that are physically
close to the protein of interest within
the membrane
not not really i mean
again we can we can just say but
basically whatever you have in the in
the in the membrane basically um
you will get extracted and then
incorporate into the solid through
system and uh
if it really binds to a membrane product
and it sticks
during the precipitation process it may
not be a contaminant but but maybe like
a some physiological uh
relevant uh protein that just
sticks to its membrane protein basically
so oh
all right thank you jens
looks like we have time for one last
question here
when expressing membrane protein slash
gpcr using
xb293 or 293. did you try membrane pro
xb293 also which one gives higher yield
for recombinant membrane protein
i can take that one so no we didn't try
that we went directly into 293 x3293
cells and haven't done any further
comparison so can't comment on that
all right well uh thank you michael
and uh thank you all michael yeva and
jens for your f uh for your time today
do you have any final comments for the
audience
yeah well thanks everyone for really
interesting questions um
please follow up with us um
afterwards because i think we have
received lots of questions and i think
we didn't have time to answer all of
those so feel free to send us an email
or get in touch with us and then we can
follow up uh offline or give us a call
um
yeah and would like to thank everybody
from this collaboration for their
contributions uh i think it's uh
it's really
really great fun and great success
working with you guys and uh again
thanks everybody in the audience for
attending this webinar
all righty
it was a really interesting
collaboration and
i'm also excited about our last target
so a really small gpcr protein
a1r
yeah i agree a lot of fun really
all right great well thank you again uh
michael yeva and jens for your time
today and for your important research we
would also like to thank labrutz and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye